Trascrizione: Maria Pericleous
Revisore: Michele Gianella
Che bella introduzione, grazie.
Bello rivedervi, è bello
essere qui a Jesolo dopo tanti anni.
Mentre stavo viaggiando
in aereo, per venire qui,
stavo pensando a quale fosse
la mia interpretazione di spazio.
E secondo me, lo spazio
è quella dimensione esistenziale
dove ci sentiamo soddisfatti
di quello che facciamo.
Ovviamente viviamo in uno spazio aperto
e con tante interazioni,
per cui gli spazi ci influenzano.
Mi sono reso conto della relazione
tra spazi interni e spazio mentale
fin da piccolo:
qualsiasi cosa facessi,
dopo un po’ mi stancava.
Che fosse andare a giocare a calcio,
a pallavolo, a basket,
a judo, andare in palestra,
qualsiasi cosa mi stancava,
perfino andare in chiesa la domenica.
Allora arriva il momento
di scegliere l’Università,
e non so esattamente
cosa voglio fare da grande,
come penso praticamente tutti, no?
E quindi scelgo
economia aziendale a Venezia,
perché la sede è vicino a casa,
e posso andare a giocare
a pallavolo la sera.
Quello è l'unico motivo
per cui non sono diventato
ingegnere o avvocato.
Però sapevo che tutto mi stava stretto,
e vedevo lo studio
un po’ come una via di uscita.
Mi laureo, e inizio a lavorare
per La Gazzetta dello Sport.
Divento il direttore del campionato
italiano di beach volley.
Io sono un appassionato di beach volley,
quindi per me era il lavoro dei sogni.
Lo faccio per tanti anni,
ho l’opportunità di girare l’Italia,
di visitare tutte le spiagge,
passare l’estate scalzo sulla sabbia -
era un sogno.
Però a poco a poco, con gli anni,
questo sogno mi stava stretto.
Avevo bisogno di qualcosa,
di nuovi stimoli,
qualcosa che mi desse di più.
Vengo chiamato da una squadra
di calcio di serie A, l’Atalanta,
a fare il direttore marketing.
È l'occasione della mia vita.
Sono giovanissimo, sono uno
dei più giovani dirigenti della Serie A,
ho 30 anni, e ho un’opportunità.
E quindi, dò tutto me stesso,
cerco di imparare,
e ogni domenica vado allo stadio
e vedo decine di migliaia di persone
esaltate per la squadra,
con questa passione incredibile.
È un'emozione pazzesca.
Però, anche a questo punto,
inizio a sentirmi stretto.
Mi chiama un’altra squadra
di calcio, il Palermo.
Sta per essere acquisita
da un gruppo del Qatar,
quindi vedo un’opportunità
di internazionalizzazione
e mi sembra una via d’uscita quasi.
Poi questa opportunità sfuma,
e quindi mi ritrovo giovane
e con un’ottima carriera
ormai consolidata,
con un ottimo stipendio
e con il lavoro che tutti sognano
o che tanti sognano.
Mi trovo profondamente insoddisfatto.
Mi sento come un leone in gabbia.
Il leone è un animale
che mi ha sempre affascinato tantissimo,
perché nonostante rappresenti
forza e potenza,
il leone nato in cattività
se torna nel suo ambiente naturale
non ha possibilità di sopravvivere.
Non è preparato alla savana.
Ed è incredibile come
un animale così forte
non possa adattarsi velocemente.
Lui è abituato a vivere
in un sistema protetto, nella sua gabbia,
e quindi
tutto è confortevole.
Ma anche se non ha esperienza
e non sa che cosa lo aspetta fuori,
e non è preparato al mondo esterno,
il suo istinto in qualche modo gli dice
che lì fuori c’è qualcosa per lui.
E questo è lo stesso motivo
per cui molti di noi,
me stesso in prima persona,
ci sentiamo dentro
delle gabbie, qualche volta,
che possono essere un lavoro,
una relazione
o la paura di essere
giudicati dagli altri.
Noi non siamo preparati a cosa sia
fuori da questo sistema,
da questa gabbia.
Però il nostro istinto, in qualche modo,
ci dice che lì fuori c’è qualcosa per noi.
Quindi anch’io, come come il leone,
sto cercando la mia savana esistenziale.
Non so esattamente cosa voglio fare,
non ne ho la più pallida idea.
Ma sento una forte attrazione
per un posto, per un luogo
che mi aveva dato
un’energia particolare:
la California.
C’ero stato, ho avuto modo di passarci
qualche mese 15 anni prima,
e mi sentivo a casa,
nonostante la cultura
e nonostante questo mondo
fosse completamente diverso.
C’è una frase nelle "Memorie di Adriano"
che mi ha colpito particolarmente,
e dice che il luogo natio
è quello dove l’uomo, per la prima volta,
rivolge lo sguardo verso se stesso.
Quindi sono carico, lascio tutto
e mi trasferisco a Los Angeles.
Con un forte senso della pianificazione
e delle priorità,
come prima cosa mi compro
una Corvette Stingray del ’78 e un surfer.
(Applausi)
In realtà, quello che sto facendo,
è cercare di capire
come funziona la cultura locale.
Sto cercando di immergermi.
Quindi evito assolutamente
il contatto con ogni italiano.
Non mangio cibo italiano,
non frequento nessun italiano.
Studio inglese tutti i giorni,
sei ore al giorno,
imparo a programmare, il  coding,
faccio consulenze di marketing
per le aziende,
e poi divento CEO
di un’azienda tecnologica,
di una start up.
Poi, mi fermo a pensare:
ho fatto 10.000 chilometri.
E sto facendo esattamente
quello che, probabilmente,
gli altri si sarebbero aspettati da me.
Mi sento dentro una gabbia.
Allora,
un giorno, facendo una passeggiata
con la mia fidanzata, attuale moglie,
cerco un po’ di esprimerle
questa frustrazione.
Dico: non riesco a pensare ad altro
che tornare dentro la mia gabbia.
Ho fatto 10.000 km,
sono il leone nella savana,
posso fare quello che voglio.
Eppure, torno sempre dentro la mia gabbia.
Mi sta stretta, ma alla fine
la conosco molto bene,
e quindi mi dà comfort.
Lei mi fa una domanda semplicissima.
Mi dice: domani mattina ti svegli.
Cosa vuoi fare?
A quel punto rimango scioccato.
È come se mi avesse aperto la gabbia.
Non ci devo pensare tanto:
ho un cappello in testa.
È da un po che sto ristrutturando
cappelli vintage.
Ne ho collezionati più di 100.
E ho imparato ad allargarli,
perché la mia testa
è leggermente  più larga
dei cappelli degli anni 70-80.
E quindi mia mamma mi ha insegnato
un po’ di taglio e cucito,
quindi ho utilizzato queste doti
per adattare questi cappelli.
Domani mattina voglio svegliarmi
e pensare solo a fare cappelli.
Ma sto prendendo
una decisione con l’istinto.
Non ho fatto un business plan,
non ho fatto analisi di mercato.
Non so esattamente se ha senso o meno.
So solo che l’istinto mi dice
che quello potrebbe essere la cosa
che mi renderà felice ogni mattina.
Ovviamente non so fare cappelli,
e quindi so solo che devo imparare tutto.
Dedico in maniera maniacale,
24 ore al giorno,
a praticare, a studiare.
Giro il mondo e cerco
di mettermi in contatto
con i migliori artigiani,
dagli artigiani giapponesi e italiani
ai mormoni nello Utah, ai cowboy in Texas.
Voglio mescolare le loro conoscenze
e capire come poter sviluppare
le migliori tecniche di realizzazione.
Ovviamente, essendo un perfezionista,
mantengo questa parte segreta.
Non voglio dirlo a nessuno:
mi sento, ho la paura
di essere giudicato dagli altri.
Ovviamente, non vedere
un risultato concreto davanti a noi
fisico, veloce, immediato,
è la molla che di solito
ci fa fare qualsiasi cosa.
Per esempio, quanti hanno mai
iniziato e interrotto una dieta?
Alzate le mani, che vi conosco.
O quanti sono andati in palestra,
e poi hanno smesso di andare in palestra?
Vedere il risultato immediato è la molla
che ci permette di fare qualsiasi cosa.
Quello che ho imparato
è che bisogna allenarsi
ad accettare i risultati invisibili.
Riuscire a trovare la gioia
nelle piccolissime azioni
che facciamo, quotidiane.
Quindi, sono pronto.
Signore e signori, da oggi
faccio cappelli a mano.
E qualcuno, anzi più di qualcuno,
mi dice: sei un pazzo.
Hai lasciato la tua carriera
per metterti a fare l’artigiano.
Alla fine è stata la migliore scelta
che avessi mai fatto in vita mia.
Oggi ho una boutique di cappelli
a Los Angeles.
Ogni mattina mi sveglio
e non vedo l’ora
di andare in laboratorio
a fare cappelli con le mie mani,
a conoscere persone,
a farmi ispirare da loro
e magari a disegnare insieme un cappello
che diventerà il loro compagno di viaggio.
Un giorno entra questo signore
sui 70 anni, distinto,
un po’ eccentrico se vogliamo.
Insieme disegniamo il suo cappello,
e dopo un mese lo chiamo e dico:
John, il tuo cappello è pronto.
John arriva, si mette il suo cappello,
si guarda allo specchio,
felice come un bambino.
Dice: "È comodissimo, mi piace molto
e mi fa impazzire il design.
Voglio farne tanti, tanti altri."
Poi mi si avvicina al bancone,
e mi dice: "Enrico, sai, voglio aiutarti.
Io ho suonato per una band
molto importante.
Se vuoi puoi usare la mia immagine
per promuoverti."
E gli dico: "Sì, John, per quale
band hai suonato?
Ero preoccupatissimo, perché ho detto:
adesso mi dirà un nome
che non ho mai sentito
e farò la mia classica figuraccia.
C'erano delle altre persone in negozio,
quindi non ha voluto dirlo a voce alta.
Allora gli passo un post-it e una penna.
E cosa scrive? The Doors!
Era John Densmore,
il batterista dei Doors.
Una leggenda vivente,
seduta nella Hall of Fame
del rock and roll.
Ha girato gli Stati Uniti
a suonare con Jim Morrison.
Mi sento emozionato come un bambino.
Non mi capita mai,
ma questo è stato oltre ogni aspettativa.
Mi sento fortunato,
ma allo stesso tempo
mi sento anche consapevole
di essermi preparato a sufficienza
per occasioni come questa.
Per concludere vi voglio comunicare
tre lezioni che ho imparato
in questo percorso.
La prima è:
seguite l’istinto,
perché l’istinto è una sintesi fantastica
di esperienze che abbiamo
accumulato in vita nostra,
e un subconscio che non siamo
capaci di tirare fuori.
Però l'istinto, senza la preparazione,
rischia di ucciderci,
un po' come il leone non preparato
ad andare nella savana.
La seconda cosa è che, molto spesso,
i piccoli passi sono più importanti
dei grandi passi.
Ho fatto 10.000 chilometri
per cambiare vita,
e sono ritornato dentro la stessa gabbia.
Poi mi sono fermato due anni,
a progettare e a pianificare.
E mentre a tutti gli altri
potevo sembrare immobile,
io sapevo dentro di me
che ogni giorno stavo facendo
un piccolo passo
verso la mia direzione.
E la terza è l’importanza delle relazioni.
Tutta la mia carriera è stata
dovuta alle relazioni,
dalla Gazzetta dello Sport,
al Palermo, all’Atalanta,
e anche a fare il cappellaio.
Mia mamma mi ha insegnato a cucire
quando avevo sei anni.
Non avrei mai pensato in vita mia
che mi sarebbe mai servito.
Mia moglie mi ha fatto capire
che quello che era importante
veramente per lei,
fossi io come persona e non il mio
titolo o la mia professione.
E gli artigiani di tutto il mondo
che mi hanno accolto,
mi hanno dedicato il loro tempo
e mi hanno svelato parte dei loro segreti.
Quindi oggi, in questo mondo
che sembra impazzito,
in questi ultimi due anni,
pensare di ricercare la felicità
sembra quasi follia.
Però alla fine, in fondo in fondo,
vale la pena di provarci.
Grazie.